a migrant camp out in the open
in one of the most dangerous cities in
mexico
this is reynossa it's known across
mexico as a black hole where several
criminal groups are battling
and even news struggles to get out
it's one of the places where u.s
authorities are sending back people that
they've caught trying to get across the
border
ngos say more arrive every day
in the day we are okay but when the
night comes it's terrifying
reynosa is very dangerous we've heard
shootouts
reynos has endured years of violence
just a month ago
a group of our men drove down the town
streets randomly killing bystanders
karina was actually kidnapped in a
nearby town
i have the scars a lady burnt me but i
didn't tell the police
i just healed myself the best i could i
was held for more than a month and a
half
are more stories like that in the camp
as well as those the u.s has sent back
across the bridge there are also
those who were trying to cross for the
first time through the front door as
asylum
seekers karina told us that its
inhabitants have got organized
now men get together and around 40 of
them patrol the perimeter each night
the conditions are tough basic needs are
hard to meet
kovid's a constant threat
and food mostly comes from donations
the numbers are fluid but there are
around 600 people there currently
ngos and government authorities are
trying to relocate them into shelters
migrants will always be a target
unfortunately they are one of the
vulnerable groups
people that don't have an address or a
home
the problem is that as soon as
authorities and civil society groups
move people into an available space
more arrive either through mexico or
across the bridge from the states
john holman al jazeera mexico